have an update on the fate of thousands
of migrants camped out on the border of
del rio texas the associated press
reports many people from the mostly
haitian group are now being allowed to
remain in the u.s while they seek asylum
that's after a number of recent
deportation flights back to haiti
manuela jorquez is in del rio manuel
good morning
good morning that ap report claims that
many have been released with notices to
appear at an immigration office within
60 days and in fact we have seen for
ourselves at one location here in del
rio where dozens were allowed to enter
as we await word from homeland security
this will likely only add to criticism
of the biden administration's response
president biden says his administration
is handling the influx of mostly haitian
migrants at the southern border the body
administration
is a man-made disaster
of inhumanity of epic proportions
republican texas governor greg abbott
visited the camp tuesday expressing
doubts that all the migrants would be
processed soon the only thing they've
shown is an incapability of dealing with
this crisis candidly in a way where they
pretend it doesn't even exist
and we're here to tell you it exists
border patrol agents that were seen on
horseback grabbing and lashing out at
migrants are now on administrative
duties pending a homeland security
investigation
the administration has sent additional
border patrol agents to the area as more
than 8 thousand migrants remain in the
camp with other sections of the river
now off limits this shallower stretch of
the rio grande has become a lifeline
many come over here to the mexican side
to buy food to bring back to their
families at the bridge camp
gregorio gianpierre arrived with his
wife and child he crossed into mexico
looking for food for them you've heard
about the deportation
and as we visited the mexican side we
noticed that authorities there are also
cracking down and limiting the migrants
movements leaving many of them feeling
stuck and of course fearing deportation
nate
now we normally don't see haitian
migrants in large numbers at the
southern border why is this happening
now
well many of them fled the island nation
after that devastating earthquake in
2010 and obtained jobs in south america
including in the run-up and during the
olympics in brazil but largely due to
the pandemic those jobs have dried up
and rumors spread that this was the best
place to try to enter the u.s
manuel bajorcas in del rio texas thank
you